oh yeah okay hey nice shirt should be
counted today yeah yeah see you hands in
your pants like I did man so good do you
redo that I always did even in public
pants I do in public too sometimes
speaking of putting your hands in your
pants welcome to the Jenna Dewan podcast
where we always put our hands in our
pants high-five
thank you guys for tuning in this week
you did yet dick you what do you want to
do this week I have an idea I wanted to
play a game because I really like to
play games
yeah the games that we play on on the
podcasts are fun I'm the kid cool when
the foot twist please Kate PUD rust what
did you have for dinner podcast they are
fun that's why we're gonna play a game
today well um we and we thought we were
gonna talk about playlist but it's like
two weeks removed now so yeah we figured
we would move on and plus uh not a whole
lot that we didn't say in the last one
that's true um so I'm happy to play a
game the game is muy clubs so we're
gonna have each of us say movie quotes
and the other person has to guess yeah
so we we spent some time preparing for
this one so it can be already five easy
five medium and five hard yes each so
there's 15 each and we're going to
deliver them and then the other person
has to guess what movie they are from
and I guess we could keep score right if
you want to keep score and if you're
watching and listening you can play
along exactly so we'll give you a second
obviously and then it's taking your body
right to get your body ready get your
body ready junior snack or some water
cuz we're gonna get so movie quotes we
don't get them moving full - hmm and
then we had to make sure that their
movies that we've both seen yeah which
I'm 99% sure these are movies yes so
this is it this is not gonna be on some
money [ __ ] like film buff [ __ ] okay
yeah get out of here
Casablanca no yeah you don't buddy you
got time
great film no but uh yeah it should be
fun I like I like films we should go see
a movie tonight later I want to see
spongebob
SpongeBob's doing well and I was so
psyched like funny it was like two
months ago and the teaser came out and I
was like losing my mind about it I know
I'm just scared that once I get them
gonna want popcorn well is it in your
calories for the day cuz we can fit in
some calories some popcorn in our
calories in our macros if we do some
jumping push-ups and [ __ ] for like an
hour straight an hours straight I'm
kidding I'm kidding
wait because I'm willing to I'm willing
to meet the demands of popcorn so if we
have to do something beforehand to earn
that popcorn it's really bad for you
it's really really not good for you at
all even a small is like so many
calories of nothing this is crushing my
dreams I know well you know what we
could do
look we could go for a little run or
something yeah or hot yoga I need some
heart you'll remember yoga it's gross
it's the best thing in the entire world
are yeah you know okay so you know you
tell me and you say like when you eat
plant-based and you don't eat any meat
or any mo parts you feel amazing that's
my vegan diet hi I feel unreal after a
hot yoga if I do hot yoga like yeah even
like twice a week I feel like on a
different level my body just works
better
ya know I understand why it feels good
definitely when you're done you feel ya
good but it's I don't I'm not like
comfortable sweating that much yeah it's
like it gets on my face and I don't like
I don't sweat a lot as I'm done yoga
it's just a hot yoga that it's just like
I feel disgusting like all you can do
after that is instantly take a shower or
you can let it dry no not ever
you know look we went the last time we
did it we went and like got some
breakfast or something after I can't
remember but it was like literally all I
could think about was did I need it just
oh yeah I mean you're essentially in a
pool of your own sweat but it's ghastly
like being in that hot environment while
you move your body like that and while
you hold those pose is really [ __ ]
amazing I don't know I'm not even a huge
yoga guy I go to yoga every once in a
blue moon but I need to start going aha
because Mike's for me makes my body feel
good feel right hey Hot Yoga is not for
me
Yoga is not okay Yoga is BAE oh yeah do
they even sanitize those rooms like
people sweat all over them no they don't
they don't say it has it all they
actually just wash it down with other
sweat from the other rooms that's what I
thought you know what they actually put
sweat into compressed co2 spray cans and
spray up if you don't stop
like when what's-her-name try to drink
Zack's well okay luckily what I didn't
want to talk about right now I want to
think about that ever again stop it sir
moving on all right now that I'm all
ready and happy now that you're all fine
deep IV and vah me oh all right you go
first
okay so we're uneasy now right yeah
we're gonna start with the easy ones and
then I'm something really easy really
all right ready first quote ever since I
started working every single day of my
life has been the worst day and before
it worse than the day before it well I
bet sure that so that means every single
day you see me that's on the worst day
of my life how is this easy alright you
gotta give me every day now I kind of
[ __ ] you alright and I I kind of cut out
the beginning let me put the beginning
back in um alright alright I was sitting
in my cubicle thinking ever since I
started working every single day of my
life has been worse than the day before
hey y'all office space there you go
sorry I [ __ ] about the first time say
good job this quote has no context how
is this supposed well I took out a
cubicle thing because I thought that
would give it away but I guess that was
essential to like the right yeah okay
your turn all right you ready so you're
one for one ding jenna gets ding ding
ding ding okay you ready yeah
can you fly this plane and land it
surely you can't be serious I am serious
and don't call me Shirley amazing
airplane yeah great it's a great quote
ding ding good easy there good easy good
easy ok next one that's me taking the
bull by the horns
it's how I handle business it's a
metaphor
brothers no no dad's bar okay you got to
give me a hint you can't just give it
away
oh sorry it's okay do you remember the
singer give you know where she walks
into is easy quote easy quote sir
suppose we stuff that people can get
like easily yes probably my my Easy's
are a little hard I guess then what are
your that's really what that's when she
walks into his office and I know it's
easy when you know what alright alright
alright I thought the delivery was gonna
seal it but I right no see you're
supposed to like just deadpan the
delivery so it's just the words okay
your turn fine I have a little hard on
my hand wrong we're about that one hmm
okay you should be able to get this over
this for most other people in westerns
movie wouldn't be that easy but how did
the tiger fly she jumped on the Sun and
rode it to tomorrow hmm
damn it we're gonna ride the Sun into
total into tomorrow I need a hand here
you want another head yeah yeah okay for
those are you listening I can't see what
I'm doing I'm just gonna raise my hand
up like this
oh the Croods I love them write this on
in tight el Mar oh that's right it is
this a good job that was a good one yeah
it's cute I love that movie okay Oh Cruz
look good quote alright I got an easy
one for you okay Stephanie that's
beautiful no Stefani like Gwen Stefani
baby mama
yeah I know Stephanie that's beautiful
no it's Stefani like Wednesday s
fantastic quote has a good one
I'm not keeping score tomorrow that's
too hard you guys can keep score how
about that let us know in the comments
who won okay are you ready for the next
easy yeah look at this stuff isn't it
neat hmm
look at this stuff isn't it neat I need
a clear ok the clue is this Mary not be
words in a song in a movie ok say the
quote again look at this stuff isn't it
neat time a timer or am I just do you
want more help yeah I need more help
look at this stuff isn't it neat oh it's
in a song is that the sound of music no
what is it I don't know what it is
looking around here you think sure she's
got everything give it to me I'm gadgets
and gizmos a-plenty i've got whozits and
whatzits galore you want thingamabobs
i got twin tell me the movie but who
cares really nothing no no no big deal
ah I mean it sounds market where the
people are I wanna see wanna see them
dancin walkin around really nothing the
Little Mermaid can you not yell and no I
didn't get that so I haven't watched a
little harness so much so yeah oh I
thought that that was like him that was
not easy I'm sorry I blew it and singing
more and louder didn't help me remember
that I'm sorry I thought it would click
no Oh bummer
ok looks like you need to watch Little
Mermaid like ASAP because it's necessary
I'll watch The Little Mermaid when you
let me show you remember the Titans okay
deal Corina right mine my next one you
ready okay I'm ready
he has a five-year plan what is it don't
die I don't know can I give you a clue
yeah old balls Oh Big Daddy toys
nice that's what that's what she's
talking about her new boyfriend he's a
five years leg what is it don't die Oh
balls
that's good yeah all right that's good
okay I have six of these oh six eight
seven easy ones oh I thought we were
doing fine yeah but I just pick the best
five I know but I threw in some extra it
does get rid of the Little Mermaid
wasn't yeah in case you didn't know any
of them slow fine got it all right okay
my next quote yep Aspen where the beer
flows like wine
damn it Jenna really yeah uh we're going
to Aspen
no nothing we landed on the moon now my
movie is up pretty bird you sold the
blind kid a dead bird Dumb and Dumber oh
[ __ ] worries I should have had Aspen
where the beer flows like wine that
should have been a Titanic I blew that
one all right good girls good one
I know they're like harder than they are
right cuz when you think of them
yourself you're like Oh duh I remember
that but then alright you ready is my
last easy okay what the hell are you
doing I'm kicking my ass do you mind oh
damn it
Oh God is it separately no no no no
night um so let me give you a little
context okay he's being literal he's
literally kicking his own ass I'm
kicking my ass
do you mind then the guy leaves jackass
I don't know he's in the bathroom in the
courthouse
oh it's liar yes you got it
I've seen ever oh my god we just kicking
this [ __ ] up okay I'm taking my ass do
you mind
all right I have two more easy ones
right you might not get this since you
didn't get the Little Mermaid pick the
better of the two then well I'm just
gonna say it
it's I Gor no Young Frankenstein okay I
have one that I know you're gonna get
do you like guacamole that's it yeah do
you like work do you like
stepbrothers right after it right before
the thing falls yes after their shitty
ass bunkbeds
thank you welcome Billy says I forgot to
ask
do you like that's good we turn our beds
in a bunk but yes you guys can do
whatever you want
oh that's yes okay so much all right on
to medium you start oh wait no I'll
start I mean I feel like this is just
gonna be fogging bad at those points
we're both yeah terribly no it's okay
that's right you know what really gets
my dick hard helping out friends you've
guessed this movie on yeah
sure Adam Scott is like talking about
like selling their house and he's like
yeah cuz you know really gets my dick
hard helping out friends he's so funny
he's amazing oh my god uh that's just my
go-to guest for everything it's a good
get you'll get like 40% of them right if
you get stepbrothers every time okay you
ready for mine yep oh that's hard okay I
need six eggs that's too expensive
Beauty and the Beast yeah you did it
that's just I need six eggs that's
really expensive yeah anything about
eggs yeah it's good one I love that song
yeah GMO internet yeah I should be him
for next Halloween guest on mm-hmm
that's not him saying that but I know
but the pony guy who the guy with the
pony
fun pony pony we done do it pony man do
it eats all the eggs that's kind of like
me I ate like three eggs you just gonna
have to get like a massive pump because
he's like on so many stairs he's huge
that'll be Mike that's like my Halloween
goal to put on Matt way and you shaped
like an upside down triangle oh my god
he's a he's shaped like mark his neck is
just married already and don't I deserve
the best maybe from the Marquess a red
uh so uh I said she's gorgeous
oh yeah here entire nose only she who is
beautiful as me so I'm making plans to
ruin
oh wait did you like underestimate how
much I love that song
no I didn't even sing it to you before
that's what you do in class like my
teacher when we were taught like in
middle school everyone we talk she'll be
like oh wait and then I would do the
same thing like she'd calling me a peer
talking about I wait like such a
[ __ ] all right here's my quote okay
maybe maybe not maybe [ __ ] yourself I
don't know it's it's it's a pretty
popular gift now um I'll tell you who
says it will that be a small enough clip
Wahlberg who's it the depart yes yeah
that wasn't that too bad of a clue that
was guess there's a lot of people in
that all right it's a great gift I love
that I love using that gift when people
ask me stupid questions write you up all
right and that's all I need I don't need
one more thing I need this hi blank him
I don't need one other thing no that's
all I need I need this gay he's grabbing
all of his things out of his house and
walking out the door with a chair and a
dog no hmm I know it but I don't know I
can't anymore forced you to watch this
movie with me because it's one of my
favorite slackers no hmm you forced me
to watch it okay as Steve Martin in it
oh the church yes
damn one other thing I need this jerk
that's a great movie yeah I'm gonna
watch that again I need to get get that
movie on the level of like knowing
quotes it's the best one cuz it's a
great movie you're not gonna like
somebody's okay sorry keep going
this game is hard okay you ready yes
dude you can't just start a slow clap at
any time and expect people to join in Oh
get up I know what this is and I don't
know what this is okay
do you want a clue yeah okay super og
Captain America
oh not another team Judi oh yeah yeah
it's like a clue clue Chris Evans or
whatever when he's on the football team
i watch that movie so much girl's kid
and then I grew up thinking no one else
[ __ ] watched it everybody watched it
it was like so weird I don't know Jamie
press love that matter it's such a great
[ __ ] movie it's like it went there I
love that you're up funny ok you ready
yep should I [ __ ] skip this one
alright I'll skip it cuz it's from the
jerk but I'll tell you and I hope you
remember put a balloon in your mouth do
you have a balloon no uh and then he
pulls a whole balloon out of his jacket
ok throw I'm good and hard she goes one
two she's gonna throw a knife at him
three four five six and then whoops
thank you anyways is that on the tennis
court yeah yeah okay remember that scene
those are this old wine bring us some
fresh wine this year raise that the
quote yeah he says that and that he
pulls a glass like out of a little under
the dispenser like that you have water
comes in and fills it up with fresh wine
this year okay uh okay medium you're not
you're not gonna [ __ ] get any leave
daddy I love him daddy I love him daddy
daddy it's animated hmm
keep going okay something her dad is a
king of the sea mmm
you already got this one wrong earlier
like I guess something a little mermaid
all right I'll give you another one okay
cuz I have a row actions I wrote seven
for this one too good you prepared for
your shortcomings
it's a Little Mermaid odd who would
steal thirty bag lunches filly medicine
that's a great club God okay ready
yeah are you lying or is he lying that's
how he says it he says are you lying or
is he lying [ __ ] a liar liar no I'll
give you a hint it's the same movie that
you just did yeah it's when they come up
to the guys porch all the kids are on
the line he says are you lying or is he
lying it's just like a moment of shitty
acting cuz he doesn't know how to
emphasize the right word
he should be emphasized you not lie yeah
are you liars he lie yeah
are you lying or is he lying my sister
and I always used to laugh at that
because if he thought it was like the
funniest like stupid acting moment I
have one that you probably won't get for
medium okay I love you girls you know
out there are four terrible fathers I'd
like to thank oh [ __ ] do it again doing
it read it again I love you girls
you know out there for terrible fathers
I'd like to think it's a womanizer in
some movie it's um
this isn't animated right part of it is
animated huh what he's a bear he's a
bear yeah Ted oh [ __ ] it's okay
that was kind of quoting Ted alright
anyways let's move on to hard I got one
more guy going oh yeah yeah um okay I
got a really [ __ ] do this one right
the only way you can beat my crazy was
by doing something crazy yourself thank
you I love you I knew it the minute I
met you I'm sorry it took so long for me
to catch up I just got stuck oh that's
really cute but I don't know what it is
it's like the last scene in the movie no
it's not it's like the climax forever
they dance together
is it animated no we watched it recently
it's a it's a pretty no oh is it a
silver linings playbook yes
nice job I got one well that movie so
much this is a good movie right it's one
of my favorite movies with Bradley
Cooper I normally get annoyed by him but
I really liked him in that movie let's
go into hard hard are you ready yeah
let's do it
I brought the big guns out [ __ ]
really hard yeah some might are really
hard
mm-hmm that's where I would play well
[ __ ] I'm looking at my clothes my head's
on it go again that's where I would play
nope
Monica Lee yes please this is a father
telling a son that's where I would play
and then they look over and they show
little babies playing it's animated
turning Nemo yeah any description trying
to tell them to be safe and they show
the little like be visually that's where
I would play yeah guys maybe Inc touch
the ball touch the pot is that just cuz
I said I'm gonna touch it does it mean
you just touch the ball okay your turn
so define so divide like peach so funny
okay gentlemen which brings me to my
next point
don't smoke crack the professor saying
this I think everything is yeah uh is
there a we only it's a coach no I
I'm blinging on the scene now but no no
you were close for first it's waterboy
ah I don't ever think of link actually
pays attention to that movie you didn't
just say that no I got you 100 times and
I'm like oh it's a class having other
stuff cuz I don't really I guess it's
not as good as I think it is cuz this
grew up watching it you know that kind
of thing we like love it
alright then I'm pretty sure it's the
professor saying that's his class yeah
it's good one
don't okay darts well gentlemen maybe
it's the coach I'm like being stupid now
what's yours
this is hard number two right yeah hard
number two I didn't put my name in that
Cup I don't want eternal glory hmm you
want a hint yeah it's not a cup it's a
goblet mm-hmm flamingo father a Goblet
of Fire
he put his name in the Goblet of Fire
Harry Potter all right you had to kind
of hold my hand but I got it I love that
[ __ ] movie all right
my heart number two okay uh advertising
has us chasing cars and clothes working
jobs we hate so we can buy [ __ ] we don't
need our lives are great sorry our Great
Depression is our lives
oh that's awful God pretty sure you've
seen this it's a class something like
thank you for smoking no what is it give
me a clue um it's a really really famous
movie yeah that doesn't know hold on I'm
getting there and it's um it's something
that people can allude to in regular
conversation when they're talking about
not talking about things what how do I
clue please okay um it has to do with
beating people up Fight Club yeah yeah
did you get that
now I do okay sorry that's bad food no
it's good
how's a great [ __ ] movie man that is
an incredible movie your turn you are
the most talented most interesting most
extraordinary person in the universe you
are capable of amazing things this is an
enemy movie mm-hmm hmm some some small
clue you yes mama the person that says
this are here how about this there's a
lot of interesting extraordinary amazing
what's a synonym for that that's left
out of here The Incredibles no damn it
if I'm good I it's not the incredible no
wonderful keep going brilliant keep
going
awesome yes everything is a lego movie
yeah nice house a good one house such a
good everything is awesome everything is
good that's a good clue I like that clue
all right ready
tattoo on the lower back might as well
be a bull's eye ah oh
I don't know what [ __ ] movie this is
like wedding crashers is it yes I see
nice I like that you got that right yes
oh I knew it
good job this one's super [ __ ] hot
all right I'm ready
my body's ready okay what happens if a
car comes we die do you like some
context yeah okay they're laying down in
the middle of his I got that much I got
that much oh oh oh oh um okay [ __ ] he's
with a girl huh dude
yeah big fish no oh I thought it was big
fish um sort of its it takes place in a
long time ago
mmm in theory yeah what would you like a
hint yeah um if you're a bird I'm over
the notebook yeah see I was thinking of
like a guy taking over we're sort of
like on the right track the big fish
right yeah okay you are yeah huh thanks
for that much credit food hair the
intact yeah yeah it was beautiful
Camille that movies soul feels I hadn't
watched that till I met you
how many more do you have one more to
life okay so I got to cuz I have one
second okay I'm taking my favorite one
for the last play my teacher told me
beauties on the inside oh that's just
something ugly people say there's a Mean
Girls
I don't know give me a clue how do you
use this movie long daddy no
Billy Madison hmm don't tell the truth
why you're lying
yeah I love them he says that to his son
so [ __ ]
that's Justin Cooper I have a picture of
Justin Cooper it says CJ CJ to see Jake
come on Julian you're so cool so cool
last one yeah all right it's hard right
you could get it let's [ __ ] do it
and who's chasing you no one
I [ __ ] know this you did don't want
me to elaborate a little bit you mean
once I get I've just silence you can
talk to them I just need a [ __ ] it's
like a moment of like alright give me
something small do okay I'll give you
the beginning more closer to be able
clone so let me get this right
she's running away he's chasing her
who's chasing you're chasing him who's
chasing you I know this movie I know
this [ __ ] movie
hey Nana you saying are you Nicola never
we never walk out how I love you
together forever Greece how it must be
to live without you only me cover me
whoo-whoo nothing I run for the bus dear
alrighty now why I can't even go stick I
say a comb in my hair now wonder what
dress to wear now I don't know say ha ha
yeah okay that takes place in a
restaurant with these lobster hands like
this no I know okay I get aa rare what
happens ever chase got married what what
what's that called
if chase got married what is that event
the wedding singer oh the wedding okay
break it down Chase's your what Oh
bridesmaids wait chase is my friend
chases my best friend's wedding yeah
oh damn it I remember that now we got
the lobsters oh look at that movie no
you didn't I loved it but I hated what
was going on because you thought that
she was gonna end up with him after
being a conniving little [ __ ] the
entire yeah my god you were telling me
how great this movie is and I'm watching
I'm like oh [ __ ] her he hated Julia roll
I hate her knees - Oh Julian but she
annoys me all right what's your last one
or do two more oh one more okay let's do
it okay
no you're done you had your time okay
I'm sorry I'm ready
are you sorry no cuz I love that song
Julian's had it with me today
somebody's gonna have to go back and get
a shitload of Dimes is that the quote
yeah that's the call so that's going
somebody's gonna have to go back and get
a shitload of time well night night
since we've seen this movie oh okay you
get a clue they're not there they're
they're not in cars and they're at a
toll is it dummy dummy no it's good
train of thought out Ace Ventura pet
detective
oh they're on horses and horses yeah
what what do you ride on a holding cell
yes nice load that quote nice I left so
hard the first clone Blazing Saddles why
is your phone um sorry I have no idea
who won but we both did wait way worse
than I thought
so bad yes it's a hard I mean it's it's
not that easy but it's fun this fun that
was fun that was fun
thanks for playing mm-hmm you can stop
seeing all right well if you guys want
to play this game
it is definitely recommended by us and
also I chase them in the
so here on YouTube I was gonna say that
absolutely because I want to see what
you guys would have picked and make fun
of us for not knowing these actually
miss Lila mermaid twice and I almost
didn't get Harry Potter thank you guys
for watching and listening to the Jenna
and Julian podcast again hoping that
next week that doesn't jive with our
outro music it's heading
that's plain red love you guys thanks
for watching you don't have it no that's
it it's over oh oh she can't hear
actually on the other